we've talked about this before it's like
you know now we're gonna have to have an
amalgamation of things in comedy
specifically and entertainment all of
entertainment right we're gonna have to
have an amalgamation of things if we
want to really get out of this yes
because you know we're not gonna get big
money on the comedy specials the movies
all it's all because but like anything
else it's not even about entertainment
just you got to do something because you
love it and the money always comes
second that's what oprah said keep
challenging who would be great for the
role in that netflix movie my friend
said they saw her do cocaine once in
mississippi in a church right and i
don't know if that's well thank god she
didn't get pregnant there but that's the
whole
and well she's gay
oprah is well with gayle right oh that's
right i mean she's a gay fully
named gayle a man named gayle isn't
laying the pipe well no no her husband's
name is steadman and you'd think steady
would play a pipe oh steadman oh the i
thought the guy's name gail king is
oprah's gay lover very interesting
you've never seen this oprah and gail
gail king is oprah's gay lover oh
beautiful deadman
is uh her
that's oprah's gay lover
steadman
her husband i believe is her beard
this is again uh bandied about talked
about okay so this is like a lot of
people know about this well people have
said it
oh there's stedman
there you go but they are legally
married
i don't know no they're not they're just
together
i don't think they're legally married
you know what's interesting at that
level
at that level you if you're steadman
it's like just live in a house
yeah like they got an estate montecito
she's got properties everywhere like
just because nothing's gonna get better
no if you divorce her even if she gives
you a care package yeah is going to get
better it's like why you know like i was
with my father this weekend we were in
providence then we drove through newport
yeah and he was just talking to me he
goes you know i don't understand like
why people who get who marry into like
these homes like this why don't they
just keep their mouths shut and just
suck everything up because we were
driving looking at these mansions and my
dad's like money doesn't solve all
problems but it solves most of them well
we're living in a time right now where
people are actually over self-actualized
we
we came from a time where see oprah
winfrey and steadman graham had a
wedding years uh ago but never got
married right
once their engagement news had been
spread to everyone in the world oprah
and steadman planned to tie the knot in
93. they never chose a specific day
no one else is interesting i don't know
if he's i got to spend time my father 75
years old all weekend with him and it's
interesting he was telling me he was
like you know you you you and and your
and your friends and your generation you
guys have too much so that's why you get
to press all the time because you have
too much stuff he's right you have too
many things my father was like i haven't
taken a [ __ ] in five days he goes if i
took a [ __ ] today
and i that would be the highlight of my
day he goes i would feel so i would feel
like a million bucks right he goes if i
gave you a million bucks you wouldn't
feel like a million bucks because you'd
look at one of your peers who has two
million bucks he goes so who's rich or
me or you he goes it's me because all i
have to do is [ __ ] and my whole life
will get immensely better so i don't
have anything he goes you have all these
things and you worry about the hole in
your ceiling now you got you know what
car do you want all you have too much he
goes get rid of he was like i want you
to get rid of when we go home get rid of
95 percent of your clothes i said that
all i got to do is text another girl and
have jasmine see it she'll do it for me
right she'll light the whole thing
[ __ ] up
yeah i said so so i can see that one two
three but he was like get rid of your
[ __ ] he goes you have your kids you got
your house get
stop over consuming and i guarantee
you'll get happier and i think that
that's the big thing like yeah with the
suicide all that we have too much [ __ ]
well
i
um i believe that there you know when
when i when i look at it this is the way
that i've always
uh internalized it i i believe that
different people need very very
different things to be happy right and
the problem with the culture that we've
created is we flattened everyone the
internet's flattened everyone and we've
basically said that everyone's the same
and everyone needs the same things and
that's such a disastrous message to
people because i know people that are
only happy when they're working right
and i know people that are only happy
when they're not working and i know you
know here's the thing knowing somebody
like my dad who's old school whatever
and then again knowing jerry right not
even about the trans stuff jerry but
knowing someone i don't know if you've
ever got a chance to know someone who's
been
institutionalized 20 years or 22 years
in prison right she said the comment the
reason why you have repeat offenders is
not because they're necessarily bad
people she was like i will never repeat
offend
i don't think she will she's like
because i i have a home with you guys i
have a life i i love the kids so i have
something to go home to she's like but
it took me a while to assimilate she
goes the best thing that happened to me
is as soon as i got out of prison cove
it happened and the pandemic and the
world got shut down because it was a
slow assimilation back in society she
said when you're in prison
and every you don't have to do anything
your meals are given to you you're told
what to do you have to go to bed at this
time you have to go wake up at this time
and this this this there's she said you
relax there's something nice she said
about like socialism and communism where
i don't i'm not forced i don't have to
go out and make a million dollars it's
not possible she goes so you're so
relaxed but when you get out into the
real world after staying in that for 20
years you start to get so anxious she
was like that i need this i gotta have
that i gotta have the right smile i
gotta have the right no she's like when
at she was like at a basic level she was
the happiest i was when i was in prison
after i got used to it because i was
like i don't have to do anything if i
don't make sense it makes sense it's
also you know we listen we live in a
country where everybody's told they can
be the boss the ceo the star the [ __ ]
athlete right everybody's told they can
be the best everybody's told and listen
there's a lot of that that makes america
like a very great place but then there's
a lot of that where it's like nobody
tells you what to do if that doesn't
work right no but this country does not
focus at all on plan b
right country does not focus every movie
everything made is about following your
dream
conquering the thing yeah but there's
very little thought given to actually
how to construct a life right in this in
this country that's why for me at least
having kids that's right helps because
i'm like oh literally
pushing my daughter in a swing or taking
my kids to school and having providing a
life for them is like that's it like
what else do i have to sell at msg all
right sure i'd love to but what let's
break the if you just make everything
smaller i think that's what my dad was
trying to tell me yeah when he's just
constipated and mad he's like just you
you have too much [ __ ] you're trying to
make your life too big make everything
small and you'll be happy i know and
that's how he lives because we'll never
do it no
no not at all
no they're not everything it's also like
the whole time i've been a little
worried i'm half sold out in burlington
yeah yeah i'm like come on you democrat
[ __ ] god it's like i'll talk about
bernie sanders here's the deal it's like
you know we all have these experiences
where you whether it's near death or
whatever you know you take a test to the
doctor he's like it's negative whatever
it is and you go how can i get upset
about anything small and then the next
day you're back to yelling and screaming
about traffic
because that's the reality that's what
it is it's just what it is it's the
reality of life i think as you grow i
was just watching on the plane out here
i watched the anthony bourdain
documentary i think what you need to do
next time you look at your father you
don't have [ __ ] enough yeah you go i
put you on the podcast do you have a
youtube channel what's your [ __ ]
digital media strategy yeah you got to
flip it on him yeah you know do you have
any live dates yeah you have
representation yeah i would say if i
make my life smart i get less gigs how
you gonna [ __ ] embezzle my money to
gamble it on [ __ ] fanduel you piece
of [ __ ]